[Music]
how dare i say
youngsters what's up everybody history
hyenas here
chrissy d yanni p welcome to our
official internet reaction video
to our bill berg trilogy it's been a
three-fight match
yeah it's like it's like a riddick beau
versus hollyfield acceptance hollyfield
verse
a couple of up-and-comers christie
stefano and uh
and the doom and gloom yanni p yeah i
mean it's just we're just trying to
figure out why we've done
three podcasts with billboard one of the
greatest comedians actually my
favorite comedian of all time i i mean
unbelievable and why they have been
three
absolute snoozers so we're trying to
pick apart the game tape now and see
what the [ __ ] are we doing wrong
that we can't just get general berta
laughing
so let's figure it out he doesn't want
to play and then he'd be like you know
my guy was just like no he does want to
play that back i really don't want to
play he's like you're going to [ __ ]
play
and then i would just play there you go
a little left there's one we get a check
that's a score
yeah exactly we could actually go
through this and see how many times we
got him to crack that was one
the worst part about this podcast is
that bill has to talk to us
right if we weren't there and he could
just find his groove yeah this would
have been a great epi
some some people just they don't they're
better just
ranting and raving on their own bill tim
dillon these guys are just even though
they're excellent
you know uh comedians they just they the
guest sometimes it's just [ __ ] hey
how great would this have been if we
just asked him to edit it down to the
beginning where he just said here's
these guys
and then he edited it to the end and he
said go follow them and that would have
been great and that would have been
great
the rest of it was him doing his
soliloquy because the kids
it's soliloquy comedy yeah it's very
shakespearean soliloquy comedy
build the solution over there yeah so
that whole block material giannis
is on fire over here those mexicans
right there
they're they're working over there for
less than
minimum paid uh wage
with my life not saying what i'm feeling
so but it's it's that's what we said as
they say isn't that your higher
resolution
kind of that what you guys do there it
is a german kid like me a lot of movies
about irish people i don't know what i
don't know what the stereotypes are like
you guys like to bury your books yes and
a bunch of different white european [ __ ]
so i would i would go to ireland to find
out what they're like
but um you know german and irish you
guys are you guys aren't as
that effusive with your emotions it's
more that's more cerebral
i know yeah so bill's just angry at
giannis now he feels really furious
this one has 84 likes so a lot of people
agree less than five minutes in
and my diagnosis is bill is interviewing
two male
whitney cummings there you go well
listen that's a compliment because she's
got a lot of money he's got a lot a lot
of money
and he just called us girls so that's
what it is what it is and he's not wrong
now yeah
gil bill's got the energy level of a 95
bill's got the energy level of a 96 year
old yeah well let me tell you something
my dad passed away at 91
and my dad had a little more energy than
that so what it is what it is
yeah um are these
meatballs tim dillon is always ripping
on
oh are these the meatballs that tim did
right now that's governor quality
idiot but you know to these people it
does seem like they're trying a little
too hard to impress bill what would you
do would you
imagine imagine that fan was on a
podcast with bill burr what the [ __ ]
would you do right not try you want us
to not try
that was another common one that was a a
lot of those in the comments
yeah those people need to ask themselves
what they would do yeah well this was
hilarious it pretty much just bill
ripping on these guys endlessly in the
friendly tone
and them just taking ridiculous [ __ ] as
well okay so that's pretty good here we
go i'm happy bill is able to help his
friends out in their career but i
couldn't make it past 10 minutes before
stopping the podcast
so there you go there it is i felt like
his guests are always trying to
that's what we got that a lot and you
know what watching it back i
i can see that we are lo it does look
like we're trying as you tell us you are
fans of the
trilogy of the three fight podcast
saga which one was the best uh which was
the toughest
out of one two and three i think it was
funny because we thought three was the
best
it turns out three got the most negative
attention yeah but
one one i think is the best in
retrospect i think the first
i like one the best and maybe it's
because we were in person and we could
all feel each other
one was the best i give bill is a real
guy
he's an authentic guy he's a guy's guy
and some and you know we're girls we're
we're
girls guys so that intimidates us thank
you so much for watching hope you
enjoyed the last video don't forget to
tell your friends
like subscribe and turn on notifications
[Music]